[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
our 27th i am sitting with
dr heather heing and wow is there a lot
going on in the world
i want to start at the very top though
in a different way
we have been frivolous at the top to get
people in a good mood but we don't have
time for that now as you can see i'm
still wearing the same outfit i was
wearing on tucker carlson
tonight last night that's because i no
longer sleep
alright so what i want to talk to you
about is
the dark horse duo plan which is now the
unity 2020 plan in order to give it
a little breathing room from the podcast
and other things
uh here's the situation we are getting a
ton
of positive feedback on this plan people
are really enthusiastic about it has
captured their imaginations
but in order to make it viable what we
need are lots and lots of people
to sign up to follow our twitter account
to look at our white paper
and to give us their email address so
that we can demonstrate
that this is an effort with enough
momentum that it can actually
carry the day so what i'm going to say
is that this podcast
is going to reach something like 100 000
people on youtube alone
in the next couple of days if it follows
the pattern of
recent live streams if all of those
people were simply to follow our twitter
account
go to our white paper and give us their
email address
it would greatly magnify our credibility
with those that we need to reach
in order to move forward so if you have
been following me some of you have been
following me for something like three
years now have you ever known me to beg
it's not my thing have you ever known me
to don't answer that
um but what i'm going to do is i'm going
to beg you to go to those places it's
absolutely free just sign up follow us
and
uh that will bring us to the next step
do you want to put this up yes i'd love
to put that up
zachary you can put up my screen here so
this is the articles of unity
uh that that you posted
and at the bottom of it this is on
medium you can find it by
searching on unity 2020 on medium and at
the bottom of
it right or or is it on the separate
website no it's down there at the bottom
okay that's so much catbell today um
inquiry inquiries
two for those who are listing and not
watching info
at articlesofunity.com there's also
if you scroll up a little bit there's a
place to just enter your email
address and then we can find you and if
you have an offer of help you can let us
know
what capabilities you bring to the table
i should also say
there has been a great deal of um
assistance help
guidance provided by members of the
amazing
yang gang who are very enthusiastic
about this plan
we are of course very interested in
whether andrew might himself be willing
to participate
on the ticket we would love to have him
it's not necessary that he be there and
many of the people in the yang gang are
of course they would prefer it to be him
but they don't need it to be him so for
those of you holdouts
please join us all right heather
are we ready uh yeah what are we ready
for uh we're gonna do a podcast
right now okay that wasn't part of the
podcast um that was a part of the
podcast but it was like a pre-podcast
okay pre pre-podcast so you want me to
just
launch into something else uh yes like
the next thing oh right all right
i think i can do that okay so um
especially since our last episode
which was a mere three days ago
in which we talked a fair bit about
the schools um
[Music]
we i've been hearing and i suspect you
have been too but i've been monitoring
specifically emails that are coming in
from people in a variety of industries
who are facing this
this monster this ideology that has
that has captured the protests on the
streets
and has captured so much else so i want
to just go through a few examples and
have us talk about them
so by this ideology you mean
critical race theory and intersectional
intersectionalism
intersectionality critical race theory
uh bastardizations
of the the kernel of
good scholarship and thinking in
post-modernism
uh that so i just places that we've
talked about it before
uh in episode 17 uh as
many other places which were was the
third
which aired we did on the third
anniversary of the beginning of the
evergreen riots and
meltdown uh we talked a lot about what
was going on
and what has been going on higher ed
right
you got something no okay you're just
smirking at me all right
um and we talked about how pernicious it
is and of course many of you have found
brett and um and me through the
evergreen story
um but uh you know gratefully on on our
end actually
increasingly people don't necessarily
know that part of our history when they
find us which is which is fabulous but
we do of course have uh well to use the
egregiously abused term the lived
experience
to back up our decades-long suspicion
deep suspicion of
this kind of thinking so that was on may
23rd of this year
episode 17 so that was before the death
of george floyd
uh we were all pretty much still in
lockdown as we
um pretty close to are still in portland
uh and we were all actively wearying of
of that um
we were not yet seeing protests on the
streets we were not
there were there were some protests on
the right about the lockdown but there
were there were not the protests that
have been
roiling america through uh for almost a
month now
no yeah almost a month now um we hadn't
seen that yet
okay so that was episode 17 uh over a
month ago
in the last episode in episode 26 we
talked about the capture of schools of
education
and therefore of the minds of children
and also the administrators of higher ed
a few episodes back in episode 22 we
talked about the movement to shut down
stem
which had uh not just that hashtag
hashtag shutdown stem
but shut down academia and a number of
others
as well uh and spoke to how a focus on
shutting down science and his associated
ways of thinking is doomed
is certain to do more civilization so
just another follow-on to that before i
move into some of the other domains
where we're seeing this
uh oxford well this is slightly old news
at this point it's a couple weeks old
oxford is decolonizing degrees in math
and science
do you hear this yup that's right oxford
and and this is not the first time
they've gone down this
absurd road uh let me pull it up uh
okay yeah you can show our screen now
zach um as
as reported in the times uh the london
paper
oxford university has revealed plans to
decolonize in quotes
its maths and science degrees and will
allow students of any subject who have
been
affected by the black lives matter furor
to seek
lenient marking now if that's not a
gameable position i don't know what is
and you know maybe to their credit they
don't say
um only for for bypack or people of
color
uh students of color they say for anyone
who's been affected
uh we will offer you um
we will offer you the option to seek
lenient marking
so i should point out it's a gameable
position
but it is also to the extent that it
just simply happens
we are hobbling our position
relative to others automatically so if
we take
something like mathematics and we
elevate people whose marks are lower
because they've been busy with something
else
then what we are doing is we are
hobbling our position in math
now i don't frankly know where math
people end up
in terms of building civilization and
innovating new things they do but it's
just
it's uh it's a little harder to detect
where they are because you know you
can't apply math directly it doesn't
make things but
let's say you do this with your
engineering school and we've actually
we've seen that i didn't pull it up but
we received an email this week as well
from uh
someone who's getting their phd in
engineering who is seeing a dissertation
being defended
uh on basically the need for social
justice in engineering
for that work they will receive a phd in
engineering
for work advocating for social
justice ad uh activism in engineering
they will receive the highest degree
awarded in engineering
so that's capture right there do know
what role engineering plays in
civilization and so the point would
be were you to have a diversity of
positions on this the engineering
schools that did not engage in this
would out-compete those that did engage
in it the students from those schools
would be higher quality they would go on
to
populate the world so the fact that we
are going to see increasingly that this
takes over
the entirety of the academy there are no
holdouts because there can't be because
power is being used to make sure there
are not
that is going to put the united states
and any other country that can't resist
this madness at a disadvantage we will
then be
hobbled relative to our enemies that
don't play this game
abroad and so the question is the we
here
is some you know weird amalgam uh of
just those who fall prey to the bullying
and the ideology
well i guess what i would say the
difficult lesson
is that even those who believe that they
are
advocating for their interests in
advancing this those interests are very
short-term
even if you come out on top you're on
top on a ship that you're setting up to
sync
and so this is not in anyone's interest
and
that that's going to be a hard message
many people won't be able to hear it but
it is necessary
that we shut down this ideology in order
that we
ourselves don't sink something that
would harm us all
everyone the protesters everyone so this
is necessary that we do this above the
objection of anybody who would stand in
our way
which does not mean that we don't
subscribe to the idea that black lives
are undervalued that that's gone on too
long and that it's time for it to stop
at that level yes of course but um at
the level of
should we destroy the republic in order
to make a statement
about black lives that is ambiguous uh
or
worse no of course we shouldn't everyone
um
is depending on us not doing that right
and just to to go full circle here
on the oxford this i don't even know
where this term decolonizing began i'm
sure it's somewhere over in critical
race theory
you know theory space um but the idea of
decolonizing
maths and sciences by allowing lenient
grading for anyone who claims to have
been affected by their own activism
effectively is this is not the first
time we've seen this
there are a lot of schools where we've
where we've seen a push for this and we
first saw it indeed
at evergreen where um the administration
in fact
um caved to almost all the demands that
came their way
and accepted uh that
students should be should be
evergreen there weren't grades but
assessed more leniently
and you know basically not have credit
stake in a way
uh if the reason that they had not
fulfilled their academic duties was
because they were too busy
rioting actually right so uh this is
this is becoming
yet another thing that's standard in the
playbook so
um i would just point out that one of
the
moves that is being made is the
partnering of the dnc with
this movement right we are seeing moves
in the direction of the demands of this
movement being advanced by the
democratic party and i would point out
that is perfectly parallel to what
happened at evergreen it is exactly what
happened at evergreen and if you think
this is going to work out well
i would suggest you look into the
position of evergreen
relative to other colleges today the
lost has been spectacular and immediate
and the fact is people recognize widely
that you don't want to send your kid you
don't want to spend
money educating your kid in an
institution that has so aggressively
signed up for something so
anti-meritocratic
you really want you know you want to
send your kids somewhere where they're
going to get
skills that will allow them to get ahead
so um
this is the same thing we are now going
to do to the united states and it just
can't be allowed to happen
so i'd like before i go on and start
talking about some of the other domains
in which we're seeing this
could you be more explicit in the
analogy that you draw
between the democratic national
committee
falling in line behind critical race
theory
spurred ideology and what happened at
evergreen
well what is it that you're looking for
uh just
you know i know i know the story but
most people don't know what happened at
evergreen like what what is the analogy
are you talking about george bridges the
president of the college are you talking
about
inslee the governor of washington like
what what what kind of
what exactly is the mirror there so uh
let's put it this way the
the argument that i'm um advancing is
that the democratic party
is corrupt this is not a secret its
corruption is centered in the dnc
also not a secret and that that entity
serves the true constituents of the
modern democratic party which are
special interests that
fuel that uh cabal so in order to serve
those interests
the uh the party cannot embrace the
interests
of working-class people right that is
antithetical to their corruption their
corruption involves parasitizing
working-class people so how do you keep
working-class people
from rebelling against the corrupt
entity
well you point them at somebody else and
in this case maybe you even point them
at somebody else
from whom they might be able to extract
well-being in order to distract them
from where
opportunity really concentrated at the
top amongst rent-seeking elites
so there is a game afoot
to partner with this movement in order
to deflect attention from the real
problem
onto some fictional version of the
problem that fictional version
of the problem being some kind of white
supremacy that is ubiquitous
inside white minds and will never be
gone right that's nonsense of course
but it is the alternative story to the
true story of where the well-being
went now at evergreen we had a
president who for whatever reason wanted
to
increase his power and consolidate it
and he made many moves
to do so basically he structured an
administration to insulate him from
blame
and to protect him from uh being
eliminated and to allow him to advance
the ball he became
effectively like you know a dictator
relative to the college and um so he
cynically
partnered with the protesters who became
rioters so quickly at evergreen
and in so doing he did advance the ball
he is going to now retire
at the end of his contract with
commendations on his
his uh bravery and wisdom like they're
so brave
there are no characteristics on which he
scores lower than those two and he's
it's like
i'm sorry bravery and wisdom to do yes
yeah bravery and wisdom
so he is going to retire at the end of
his contract he's actually going to be
allowed to teach at evergreen at a time
when we're you know i mean this
just doesn't make any sense relative to
the story so he made it he succeeded in
advancing his own ball
he made 300 000 a year at the head of
this college
but the college isn't going to survive
it so the point is the dnc
is protecting itself it's going to
partner with this ideology this ideology
is
truly going to wreck the republic and
frankly it's not even going to get the
chance to which is something we should
talk about because
if you just let the dnc go and there was
no
other force out there then yes okay they
would unhook all of the protections
america would become a race first nation
in which we
prioritized everything intersectionally
but we're not going to get there because
you have a large well-armed
white population that now has an actual
reason to fear what comes next
and that is going to boil over into
mayhem
very very soon and so um
zach did you get the picture of the
histogram
so i want to just make a quick argument
here
okay so you're going to have to allow me
to draw you a picture is it a url
it's it's not um so you have all seen
bell-shaped distributions normal
distributions a scatter of dots that
roughly makes the shape of a bell this
describes many many processes it
basically describes
almost any process in which you have a
large number of factors
and that results in some very small
results some very large results in the
bulk of results being
towards the center we are now seeing
something that hints at the far tail of
a distribution
of violence right we are seeing events
happen now in the streets regularly that
suggests that we are headed to the
far tail of triggering events so
zach could you put up um the federalist
article
so zack is going to put on the screen an
article
that describes an event that many of you
will have
noted in which a vehicle
was blocked by protesters this was all
captured on film
vehicle was blocked by protesters
the occupant of the vehicle was then
threatened with a gun
i believe you can see it's not so clear
that i could swear it was a gun myself
but people have looked at it
somebody one of the protesters pulled a
gun on the
driver of this car the driver sped away
hitting one of the protesters
and npr reported this as a violent white
supremacist attack on protesters with a
vehicle
saying that these vehicular attacks are
on the rise
and you know they got it wrong famously
but nonetheless the point is we are
seeing
people in their cars blocked by
protesters
and a confrontation in which violence is
threatened people are going to get hit
by cars it's not going to be long before
somebody is killed
i mean it's obviously happened before in
ferguson
that it was a true white supremacist
attack but we are now seeing
charlottesville sorry my bad
can you show the other um vehicular
the provo provo utah so this is
uh much more recent i mean we're talking
scale of weeks anyway
here we have a video this is provo utah
the black lives matter demonstration
the uh here's the gun shot this is just
a
citizen driving through yeah as far as
we can tell citizen's driving shoe but
but what you hear is gunshots
um so what i'm telling you is
we are far down the road towards a
conflict
that will be unstoppable between people
who
now have a reason to fear what's coming
next what will unfold politically
and this movement which is discovering
its power
that is going to be a catastrophe for
the united states and
you know i hear a lot of people talking
about well you know
2024 that's our year i don't know who
you know given the shape of the
distribution and the number of these
extreme events we are now seeing i don't
know who it is who's confident that we
make it to 2024 without
crossing some uh some rubicon from which
we cannot come back
okay let's talk about the non-violent
ways that this happens okay
um so i mean unless you have more of
this no no
uh we've been talking about the capture
of higher ed we've been talking about
the capture of the k-12 schools and
therefore the minds of the children
we've been talking about the shutdown
stem movement we've talked about
uh the capture of journalism uh in one
of the episodes i don't remember which
one recently we talked about uh the
change
in the editorial board at the new york
times and it's happening all over
um now we are hearing also and really we
have been
ever since evergreen blew up receiving
communiques to this effect but in the
last week
they have increased a lot about many and
myriad attempts to take down the arts
so you've got if you're going to attempt
to take down sciences and arts
um as you know within within academia
then that's basically
all of scholarly and creative production
um
yeah yes the humanities and social
sciences are real but science as an arts
is sort of the bastions
of what is i feel what is absolutely
necessary
uh for a uh democratic society
to pursue truth and compassion for all
of its people we need both we need
sciences and we need arts
we've seen we've demonstrated uh some of
the attempts to
weaken or dismantle stem and here the
arts
we have um let's see i've just got a
couple
of examples last time brett you showed a
couple of examples of theater
what's going on in the theater in
atlanta in particular
um art of new york has posted a blog
with the title
yes i have white supremacist tendencies
and i am working to change
here's a quotation from it um
i'm not going to name this person so and
so so
the person writing is a is an executive
director who is white
and this person writes such and such
explained that as a white executive
director
my act of redirecting a conversation
between two african-american speakers
was itself an example of white
supremacist behavior
the idea that you cannot interject in a
conversation
based on the fact of the race of the
participants
being evidence of white supremacy that's
also the end of discourse it's not just
it's not just
the end of art okay so um
here is hold on a second zach
my trackpad isn't working here's an la
times
article which you can show zach uh from
it's actually a couple weeks ago
titled the spreadsheet that shook the
theater world marie cisco's not speaking
out list
so here's a single a single woman who
created a
public google spreadsheet and we've seen
this before a public google spreadsheet
which you can click on
in the link in the article called
theaters not speaking out
and um what they've done
is we have cat madness in here at the
moment um
she has she's created this and she you
know she says in the article that she
expects it not to
go very far but she wakes up and there's
you know many many
uh theater troops and um and such that
are
on the google sheet they have um
boy i can't find oh um among other
columns
um which theaters have made statements
apparently if you don't make a statement
don't put up a black square
on the appropriate day um you're you're
on the on the list um which
what the action steps are of the
theaters uh whether or not they have
specifically mentioned the black lives
matter movement
and also the race of each theater's
artistic director and board chair
so that is what is passing for social
justice
activism right now you can take that
down zach
um we have
also oh man we just so the the examples
go on and on and on we're hearing from
artists and directors of art companies
and galleries across
many media in music in dance in 2d art
more they see the thing coming for them
they're not sure what to do
they're asking us what to do and we
don't have
all the answers by any means and it's
always going to be context specific
but i'm going to get to shortly here i'm
going to read
with the author's permission something
from a letter
that that i got that um
that i think helps point out
that would you feel like you're all
alone
and you have not yet raised your voice
and said i don't think so
i don't agree with this this doesn't
look to me like
widespread systemic racism or white
supremacy or whatever it is
until you stand up of course you think
you're alone of course you do
and as soon as you say something every
story we've
heard has people saying and then my
colleagues started coming to me quietly
at first and saying thank you thank you
for saying something
i don't know what's happening i wish it
would just go away but it doesn't look
like it's going to go away
so those are some examples in the arts
uh shutdown literature is also happening
and there's there's no hashtag as far as
i know but um
we we've spoken in earlier episodes
about the
ridiculous capture of young adult
fiction
uh we spoke about recently the novel
american dirt which was at risk of being
canceled because the author of the novel
is not herself a perfect match
demographically for her protagonist
the booker prize which is probably the
most prestigious
literary prize for fiction in the known
universe on this planet
has fired several people including a
vice president who presumably not
coincidentally
had recently been in an argument with a
trans model um
arguing uh for things the likes of which
jk rowling has been arguing
we need literature as i've said as i've
said before we need literature to show
us
what we ourselves have not yet seen to
reveal our world's
um that that are possible and that other
people are living but that we haven't
lived
and if the only literature that is going
to be possible is that
written by people who have frankly done
no imagination
only written their own experience that's
called memoir and there's a place for
memoir but there is also a place for
fiction
um can i just jump in here and say
there are places where human beings sort
out
that which is not black and white right
they include
literature they include theater they
include
in more recent times uh movies and
um this uh long-form television
they include humor all of these things
are under attack because the idea
is nuance is actually the death of this
ideology
if there is nuance this ideology cannot
thrive therefore
it has to drive everything one side or
the other it either has to paint you as
a white supremacist or you have to
embrace it and sign up to do
whatever it asks there's no middle
ground and that's the problem
that's how you know that you will have
to stand up
because it's asking you are you willing
to do anything
for this be for this ideology and if the
answer is no there are things i wouldn't
do
then don't let it march you there
because that's what it's doing it's
marching you one step at a time
yeah and actually your mention of humor
uh
stand-up comedians were the canaries
here i mean there were there were
many of us within academia who were
seeing this and who were talking about
it
mostly within academia um you know most
of us didn't have public platforms at
that point but that
but but fine i don't know that's an
excuse
um but for i think decades at this point
we have been hearing
stand-up comedians say you know what i i
can't do this on college campuses
anymore
and you know the idea
which we heard when evergreen blew up
that this was limited to college
campuses that what happens on campus
will stay on campus no it will not
of course it won't the whole point of a
college campus is that what happens
there
is educating people to live the rest of
their lives in a full
and complete and and and democratic way
the idea the whole point this is the
point so
to have the argument come back to us
that of course the parts that we don't
really
like and might be dangerous will stay
there but the parts that we do like will
leave the campus
that makes no logical sense at all and
of course it didn't happen
but there's also an aspect of hope here
because comedy went through a very bleak
period as a result of this and yes
not coming to college campuses was one
thing but it also had an effect on
what humor sounded like for i don't know
a decade
but we are beginning to see you know it
is interesting that it's some of the
most powerful comics
around who are able to fight their way
back against this but we've seen
uh dave chappelle joe rogan uh
ricky gervais um
david i can hear the music in my head
enthusiasm uh these
guys have uh really pushed the ball back
the other direction and they have carved
out the
right to make jokes that are edgy which
is necessary if jokes aren't edgy
they're also not useful and i'm speaking
evolutionarily
human beings have humor for a reason
that reason has to do
with sorting out difficult things
discovering what's in other minds when
they won't tell you
and it is necessary you want to solve
racism that's how you're going to do it
and if you don't believe me
go back and watch chappelle's show okay
that's how we sort out racism
that's right so before we move on to
public services
from arts and literature i offer a quote
from joseph brodsky who was
a nobel laureate and in fact the united
states poet laureate
and this is a quote from his opening
remarks as united states poet laureate
in october of 1991.
he says by failing to read or listen to
poets society dooms itself to inferior
modes of articulation
those of the politician the salesman or
the charlatan
in other words it forfeits its own
evolutionary potential
for what distinguishes us from the rest
of the animal kingdom is precisely the
gift of speech
poetry is not a form of entertainment
and a certain sense not even a form of
art
but it is our anthropological genetic
goal our evolutionary linguistic
beacon hell yeah extraordinary that is a
great quote
yeah yeah and i mean he's i i want to
finish
actually the hour with another quote
from him but this i mean he's
his his essays he's a poet but as we
talked about with regard to orwell
right um poetry and narrative fiction
go more go farther generally
than essays do and you know a a speech
at at a commencement
ceremony or as you accept the role of
poet laureate
can be powerful in a way that can thread
between those things
so um okay
that's that's some of the evidence that
arts and literature
are also being come for um
here's we we've had so many people
uh from what i have sometimes derisively
called cubicle land and that's not fair
but you know not people working in the
arts not people working in the sciences
specifically
people you know the vast majority of
white-collar workers out there in
america
who are saying it's not mandatory yet
but what do i do when it becomes
mandatory the training
um what what what what should i what can
i do
and so one of the most
um the most remarkable communicators i
got
uh this week was from a um professional
she so she authorized me to share this
i'm anonymizing her slightly here
um she's a professional woman in her 30s
who works at the department of human
services in minneapolis
which of course is we all know is the
city at the epicenter of current
protests and riots
she is a long-term resident she loves
she loves minneapolis so deeply and
cannot believe what she is
what she is seeing there i'm not
actually going to read the part of her
uh letter that talks about what she's
seen in the riots i mean i i could i
suppose i could come back to it but
um just these two paragraphs um
with regard to what she what she wrote
to me and like i said she told me
she actually she told me i could share
this but only if i sp if i
said i was not going to say what city
she was in to help anonymize her and she
said no please say that i'm from
minneapolis because i want people to
understand that what they're seeing
in the videos is not what my city is and
i
i just felt that so strongly because i
felt we both felt that so strongly with
regard to evergreen
that is not the best of what evergreen
was that's not the best that's not what
it could do
um it was allowed to be taken over as
this letter writer says my city has been
allowed to be taken out it was a small
quadrant that became
the college almost instantly yeah
exactly
so this is a a professional woman in her
30s who writes
in part after george floyd's death over
the last month i have received a
blitzkrieg of communications from my
union
leadership and various equity committees
about the structural changes they wish
to force on our union
in our programs and on the agency as a
whole the communications which i've
attached this message
are riddled in buzzwords from critical
race theory and includes instructions
for white people in particular to do the
anti-racism work my job is not now in
immediate jeopardy
so far everything has remained voluntary
but our commissioner has informed us the
agency will require anti-racism training
in the future and possible restructuring
of programs
this makes me very nervous i fear that
if this ideology takes hold it will
destroy the agency
i also worry that my job might be on the
line in the future if i refuse to do the
training or speak out publicly against
it
i've spoken to one employee who's also a
good friend about my fears
and he seems to think that everything
will be fine because if things get out
of hand
people will speak out against it when
the time comes i'm not so optimistic
so i do have one more paragraph to read
but that just gives me chills reading it
aloud
people will speak out against having
faith in the idea that people will speak
out against it when the time comes
misunderstands that you won't know when
the time has come
what this author is saying is i think
the time has come and i don't know what
to do
and that's that's what we're hearing
from people and i would say
one thing and i did respond to her at
some length but one thing i would add
what i responded with was
if you have a friend who can see who can
see this as you can
and they think uh that people will start
speaking up later
they won't and you need you need
to talk to him your friend this this
will be one of the easier conversations
because he can already see it and say
why do we think that people will start
speaking up later
it will only get harder to do so ah it
will only get harder to do that's the
key not only will they not
know because the time is now right this
is already out of hand if they're not
speaking
up now then they've misunderstood where
we are um but the problem is
that this ideology is discovering how
powerful
it is and because it's discovering how
powerful it is at the point you get to
this mythological place where you're
gonna know it's gone too far
it's ability to leverage against you
will be that much greater so
i mean we know from experience it
doesn't happen the people who were going
to stand up
did so early yeah right i mean we have
not
accumulated almost anyone in the
evergreen community after a certain
point everybody who
kept their wits about them spoke up in
one way or another
and then the rest have been silent and
so even the ones who know better
silent to this day yep that's right
so one more paragraph from the same
letter writer
should i say something publicly now or
wait until the mandatory training starts
and refuse to take them
take the training and offer criticism
quietly warn others against this
simply ignore it and hope it goes away i
know you've offered general advice
already but speaking publicly now may
not be the best approach
if i'm going to stick my neck out i'd
like it at least to be effective do you
have any advice for what to do about the
changes enacted by the minneapolis city
council
should i call it a lost cause and
abandon the city i love
should i buy a gun
so i told you last night as i was
reading this i said i've just received
an amazing letter and i want to read
part of it so this was your first time
hearing
this as well um i relate to it
and i do think we have an obligation to
speak to the question
what i can't say is that there is a good
answer there are better answers and
worse answers but there are no good
answers
yeah um which that's exactly right i
mean i could even
i could read part of my answer here and
it's it but it says
it's as much much of that yeah
so i think one thing is you have to
start thinking on a different time scale
right there is no solution to your
problem in the moment
by design and how do you know that
that's really what's going on how can
you tell it's also confusing you're
confronted with people
who you know to be good who are saying
things that sound like they're
motivated by the right stuff and yet the
result of them
is that you don't have any choice about
what you say next whether you believe it
or not
right so what's going on well you can
tell
that this is not what it seems it is not
advocating for
the values that it claims because
there's no diversity were there
were this a natural movement rather than
an authoritarian first movement
diversity of ideas
well that's just it is you would have
diversity of opinion
over these things and you know that
because they're not
clear like let's say that it was true
that sex was not a binary
right well
it's certainly not clear that sex is not
a binary there are certainly a great
many
arguments on the side of it being a
binary now you and i would say of course
it is a binary and there is in fact one
unfudged
binary at the bottom of it that explains
this in
things for hundreds of millions of years
prior to humans so
500 million years of uninterrupted
sexual reproduction
in our human ancestry alone
it's about gamete size it's about which
gamete you got yeah big ones are little
ones yeah yeah
so anyway but let's say that you know
somewhere
some quadrant of biology had discovered
that oh in fact it's not a binary
well that thing would not overnight turn
us
all into people who believed sex wasn't
the binary would take time
for the very facts to sort themselves
out and to figure out which of these
things
dominated the discussion the fact that
it goes instantaneously from science
would claim that sex is a binary to
science knows that it is not a binary
and you have no choice but to say that
online because
to be a holdout at this moment is
evidence of mental defect and prejudice
is preposterous you can tell it's the
point
you know you hear uh where did i was it
uh douglas murray who was just invoking
the medium as the message
in this case the medium is the message
and the medium is
authoritarianism that's the message this
is about power
right it's about power the claims are
secondary
and they are the way you can tell that
this is uh that this power is
substantial because you know there's not
a college in the country
that has resisted this completely you've
got one not even chicago
yeah chicago has resisted it better than
the others but the fact that
everybody is being pulled in this
direction tells you something's wrong
there ought to be at least two schools
of thought
and there aren't so um anyway that
this is the situation you're facing and
if you try to solve your problem
on the scale of the individual
discussion how do i get out of this
individual discussion without saying
something i don't believe
um or getting myself fired
you have a problem if you realize that
this
thing that has come for you is not
stable
okay it cannot last it could topple
civilization
but it cannot last something comes after
and if you think about that some place
after
and where you would like to be relative
to it then you're playing a different
game already
so you know eric has perfected a
kind of method for detecting the
maybe there needs to be a coefficient of
authoritarianism that you can detect in
the following way so what he'll do
is he will tweet a claim
that he knows to be controversial and
then he will have
a poll accompanying the tweet and so now
what he's done
is he's triggered something where you
get reactions to the very same thing
the tweet in two forms the form of the
discussion
and the form of an anonymous poll and so
what you know is that the audience is
actually the same
right because it's who saw the tweet and
the discussion
will sound very much like the
discussions we are all now hearing right
where you'll get a huge number of people
broadcasting their horror at the
controversial idea that you've just
expressed but the poll
reflects the opposite that people
actually widely understand the truth
they just can't figure out how to say
that's so interesting i only remember
one of these i've only seen one of these
which is from
years ago around about when uh when the
de moore memo was happening
and he said something like who would who
uh would you rather
uh talk to on issues of sex and gender
biologists
uh gender scholars neither maybe it was
just two right
and it was like 99 biologists which you
know it wasn't quite that high but it
was close it would be easy to say well
of course that's eric's audience
right but in the comments and the
comments it was um there were a lot of
activists there were a lot of gender
activists uh in the audience so i didn't
know he'd been doing this
since then he's done it several times
and it's very effective but anyway the
message of it is the following thing
you have no ability to directly detect
what people
actually think around you and we saw
this so clearly evergreen
so here's the sequence right something
is happening
you for whatever reason if you're me you
can't stomach
this thing happening and not saying
what's actually true
you know this is a threat to the college
this is not doing
black people any any favors you say this
there's an outcry against you
and then there is this private flood of
people who come to you and say thank you
thank you for saying what you said we
agree we just can't say so out loud
so you know if you step into the line of
fire you'll detect
something is going on and then oh the
final thing in the sequence is
you then say to the email audience or
whoever it is you say look
there's a culture of fear on this campus
i can tell you it's here because lots of
people come to me privately and they
tell me they agree but they say they
can't possibly say this publicly
right and then people say who is it who
is it who came to you
and it's like there's no culture of fear
prove it right tell us your sources tell
us your sources
and so anyway that puts you in a damned
if you do damned if you don't situation
so of course you're a good person you
don't tell them your sources but then it
looks like maybe you're making it up
so anyway what i would say is the first
thing you have to do
is put out feelers to figure out who
else
is made uncomfortable by being forced to
say things they don't believe
even if the only thing you can do you
sit privately
somewhere where no one else can hear and
look each other in the eye and say you
know what
i don't know how to resist this but this
is not okay
if you can say that to another person
you have found
the bottom rung of the ladder of
climbing your way out and that's
that's something uh that i didn't know
to do
at evergreen and in part because we had
each other so we were talking to each
other
constantly uh and there
there were a couple of other people who
were public but
i can actually imagine in my mind's eye
right now and off camera i will tell you
who i'm thinking of and i'm positive you
will have
the same sense i remember seeing a few
people whom i really liked
being more and more circumspect walking
on campus with their eyes down
hiding out in their offices being much
less public coming to
fewer meetings uh and
as it turned out you know later we we've
found
out that they were actually having
exactly the same
um yeah cap bell issues again um exactly
the same concerns
um that we were but they were responding
to those concerns
by um by just not looking at and hoping
it would go away which is which is
a lot of our instincts please please can
let's just stop
right and i didn't i didn't recognize
those signs
at the time i just thought you know
they're introverts these are academics
um whatever but um i think actually if
if you're looking for people who are
also
concerned about what's happening those
colleagues of yours
whom you see less around who seem less
willing to be engaged in casual
conversation
may well be hiding in part because they
don't want to be dragged into one of
these
so-called casual conversations in which
they're basically forced uh to make a
claim
they don't believe and once you've
started doing it it's very hard to stop
exactly so you and i had a little bit
different experiences because just
by happenstance you were on sabbatical
as evergreen
really came apart the final five months
i was not on campus yeah actually
so for me i was you know as we've told
people who follow us
many times evergreen's model was such
that we were in
full-time contact with our students like
it was a full-time job
the one class we taught was a full-time
job for the professor and for the
students so we knew each other
really well and some of these people had
been one of our students for years so i
knew them even better
so i was talking to them about what was
unfolding which kept me grounded and i
think
actually probably in some way
had an effect on the event itself
because as i discovered when mike nena
talked to me
about what he was seeing looking at the
video it dawned on me
what the protesters were expecting the
day they protested my class
they were expecting a mutiny that
students in my class would feel this
pressure
and that they would jump ship because
obviously the better deal was to
you know turn on their racist professor
and join these
good-hearted protesters and not a one
did right in part
not a one did yes they knew us very well
but we had also looked each other in the
eye and said this is not okay
we had talked to each other about the
fact that there was something going on
it didn't make any sense
and you know that camaraderie actually
emboldened them and it emboldened them
emboldened your story my students yes
who you know as i've also pointed out
multiple times
actually some of them defended me
even as dangerous as that was for
students to defend me during that crazy
riot students of mine actually stood up
and said no to this mob of hundreds of
people so
that was an incredible act of bravery on
their part especially the students of
color who did it because
students of color who go against the
narrative are a bigger danger to the
narrative so they get punished more
brutally
so anyway seeing all that so what did
you do
what did you do in advance that produced
that you know we've talked before
about the particular curriculum you were
building and about informing people of
what
uh of you know how evolution works and
how it renders
behaviors um in people who both claim to
be enemies and friends
but more important than any of those
things was you actually created
connection and community and trust
with these people who were your students
in advance
and you know most faculty don't bother
most faculty don't even imagine that's
on the list of possibilities frankly
but i think also most
supposed communities haven't actually
done that they haven't actually looked
at each other and recognized
that they're dealing with another human
being just as flawed
just as weird just as
capable of waking up on the wrong side
of the bed as you are
and that they will sometimes speak
poorly they will sometimes make mistakes
and they will sometimes be capable of
great courage
and and and amazingness
and it is we all imagine that the person
we're dealing with
is a caricature at especially when
they're coming at us
and none of them actually
very few people are actually that kind
of black and white
caricature of evil or good oh yeah
they're very few evil people
a lot of confused people there are a lot
of people who are easily corrupted but
evil is a very rare phenomenon because
it's not a good strategy pure evil yeah
um yeah so you know you and i
for reasons that had nothing to do with
any of this for the entire time we were
teaching at evergreen which was 15 years
we're always very genuine with our
students we always cared about our
students in a way that wasn't really
required by the job
i mean it wasn't at all most the people
who had the job didn't do it i actually
got laughed at by my co-faculty on
occasion
yeah i mean this this points to you know
the the rot at the core of that
particular institution
at a place where you were supposed where
teaching and community were supposed to
be paramount yeah
the idea that someone that i was
actually engaged in co-teaching with
would say to me why are you bothering to
learn their names right
it's just the first level of respect and
of course you and i both went far beyond
that but why are you bothering to learn
their names
yeah at the founding of the college
every single person would have done it
the way you and i did it
they would have invested in their
students they would have cared about
them individually
but that had broken down at the point
that we got there so that it was the
exception and not the rule
but we always cared about our students
as individuals and
we didn't lie to them we told them the
truth and we were you know
in a way that you just couldn't in under
normal circumstances at a different
college
and so i think the thing is
building human trust is the antidote to
this thing that breaks down human trust
and if you're trying to solve the
problem we don't know the particulars of
your situation
but in a general sense that's the route
out is to figure out
even if you can't figure out how to
resist who
else understands that that's necessary
who else understands
that you're gonna have to um tell lies
to keep your job potentially and you
know i'm not telling you
i would much rather you didn't you know
i don't want you to tell lies in order
to keep your job but
i'm not in your situation you may need
that job
and you know it's nobody else's to tell
you you can afford this but
what i will tell you is that to save
your job now
empowers the beast and the beast is down
the road not gonna stop asking
it's about power and um we can't afford
where this is dragging us so
any way in which you can figure out how
to maintain
resistance and most importantly maintain
the clarity in your own mind
that is absolutely essential
you want to talk for a minute about
reddit sure
read it yeah so they came out with a
brave new policy
for a brave new world their new policies
state that communities and people that
incite violence or that promote hate
based on identity or vulnerability will
be banned
okay while the rule on hate protects
such groups it continues
after a little while it does not protect
all groups or all forms of identity
for example the rule does not protect
groups of people who are in the majority
[Music]
hard to even know what to say yeah well
yeah uh it makes me wonder
so many things uh one thing is this just
one of
many things that this brings up for me
is um
majority where assist how right does
this mean that indians
who are writing from india are not
protected by reddit's new
policy on hate speech because they're
not the minority when they're in india
being indians and all
how about women among undergraduates
women are now majority among
undergraduates how about women
teachers yeah what about
the changing demographics of the entire
world
right what what what were they thinking
what could they possibly be planet earth
i am going to bet yeah
that people of color outnumber white
europeans
right so who's protected here what is
what could they
what what stable context could they
possibly have imagined and isn't that
exactly the error made by
so many fields before you know this this
would be in the weeds but this is
exactly the area that ecology makes
i mean this this the idea that like
we're going to pinpoint a moment
in time that is the moment that we are
fighting against most or
trying to recover the most one moment
and
have and then write this thing which
refers to majority as if that doesn't
shift
constantly this is so enumerate i mean
and
everything else that it is it's a
numerator of course no it's beautiful oh
god it's
brilliant it's the most beautiful piece
of strategy of all because
the point of that law that they have
instituted in reddit land yes
is you know what we mean you know who
we're talking about which means that the
crime will be attacking people who you
know are under our protection
and attacking people that you know we
don't like hell we encourage that
so the point is look don't come at me
with your numerate
garbage yeah you know you know what that
policy means
and so and of course and of course we
all do yeah and we know exactly
and the problem is the problem is
there is no longer any court where you
can take this
okay this the the horizontal nature of
this revolutionary force
means there is no place that you can go
and make that argument about this is
enumerate what are they even talking
about
there's no one who's going to listen and
we know this in a sense
because of the parallel evictions that
we saw yesterday on
reddit and youtube and medium and i'm
not sure where else but
the point is that was not an accident
you know what that was
that was the same damn thing when
terrorists coordinate bombings in
different cities
they are telling you something about
their power this wasn't we got lucky
this was good enough that we could do
this in two different places at once
right and so this was a coordinated
attack
now what we don't know is what preceded
it
what confrontations happened inside of
youtube
and inside of reddit and inside of
medium
that caused this to happen in other
words who backed who against the wall
and who caved and how is it that we in
the world
are now going to be left with the
aftermath well they've got everyone
in a position of power who
is white they're asking them to claim
white supremacy
exactly what we saw them ask the
president of evergreen to say which he
managed to
admit to on camera to hbo um
which was you know a brilliant moment
early in in that story but
people are doing it oh you say i'm a
white supremacist
oh i didn't think so but oh well if i
was questioning your statement i guess i
am so so
look you know this is a believe it or
not this continues to be a problem for
us even though we have
a large audience of people who have
gotten this message in one way or
another the world has confronted them
and they've
stood up to the challenge but for a
second i want to talk to the people who
are signed up for this movement
but who i don't think would be signed up
for it if they really understood where
it was headed and
what is motivating it you know that's
not to say the anger in the street i
think the anger in the street is
legitimate but
the anger in the street is about the
fact that well-being
that productivity was
captured by rent-seeking elites
and the fact is when you sign up for a
movement that's going to go after
ordinary people people of ordinary means
rather than go after the rent seeking
elites
who caused the problem rather you know
actually
partner with the rent-seeking elites who
caused the problem and go after people
of ordinary means who didn't cause it
and aren't guilty of the thing that
you're accusing them
you're just a sucker why would you do
this
why would you not recognize that
actually there is a huge majority of us
who would sign up for a movement that
was
actually interested in draining the
swamp and actually interested in going
after the rent-seeking elites who have
captured both of our major parties and
are preventing us from ever having any
important influence on policy
that's who we should be going after so
what the hell are we doing why are you
being a sucker
why would you deliver the rest of us
into the maw of this beast
don't do it let's go after the people
who actually absorb the well-being that
belong to us
let's let's let's do it yeah let's and
another thing no i don't have another
thing
um allow me to end on two more
quotations sure
one more from joseph brodsky uh
who again was u.s poet laureate and
a nobel uh prize winner in literature
this is from his commencement address at
williams college in 1984.
he said the surest defense against evil
is extreme individualism
originality of thinking whimsicality
even if you will except eccentricity
that is something that cannot be feigned
faked or imitated
something even a seasoned imposter
couldn't be happy with
that's beautiful yeah and alexander
suljanison
who of course is the author of the gulag
archipelago
said this the strength or weakness of a
society depends more on the level of its
spiritual life
than on its level of industrialization
neither a market economy nor even
general abundance constitutes the
crowning achievement of human life
if a nation's spiritual energies have
been exhausted it will not be saved from
collapse by the most perfect government
structure or by any industrial
development a tree with a rotten core
cannot stand
man so people have seen it before
they've understood
all right before we close i am not going
to ask you to like
like subscribe make a comment i just i'm
foregoing it what i'm going to ask you
to do is something concrete
please please please energize the unity
2020 ticket if i can wear a jacket
then you can sign up for those things
all right it's not that hard
we need the momentum and if we get the
momentum we can actually change things
four months from now you'll feel so much
better
all right see you shortly we will have a
q a in 15 minutes
uh on a link in the description
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you